people talk a lot about what it means to
be human about what separates us from
the animals some of that is lyrical love
and empathy and stuff I personally think
it could be pinned down to the fact that
we are the only animals who feel shame
in defecating but whether it makes us
human or not we are the only animal that
from an early age six in my case in
dollis Hill is aware of the
inevitability of death so it is
impossible to look at the repetitive
creation of Legends across every culture
and throughout history which in one way
or another outsmart death and promise
immortality without concluding that God
is a projection of a very fundamental
desire within within us for it not to be
so
[Music]
inevitable